الارهاب واصبح اكثر انتشارا ويشكل تهديدا
وجوديا للسلم والامن الدوليين تحذير امم
جديد يدق ناقصى خطر انتشار التطرف في
مناطق مختلفه من العالم بسبب التكنولوجيا
الحديثه
[موسيقى]
للارهاب والتطرف العنيفه يقول بيان مجلس
الامن الذي وافق عليه جميع اعضاء المجلس
ال 15 في نهايه اجتماع مفتوح حول مكافحه
الارهاب
المتطرفه للتكنولوجيا الجديده التي تتم
عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي للترويجي
لنفسها وتجنيد مزيدا من المقاتلين وتحديدا
على من الصادق مثل تويتر وفيسبوك ويوتيوب
وتلغرام
التنظيمات الارهابيات استغلت التكنولوجيا
ايضا لجاني الاموال وتحويلها عبر العملات
الافتراضيه بيتكوينز لضمان اعاده تعقبها
دوليا
الطائرات المسيره تكنولوجيا اخرى استغلتها
تنظمات لتنفيذ هج ارهابيه
واكثر من ذلك جماعات اخرى ابقت على
وسائلها القديمه لجمع الاموال ايضا ابرزها
استغلال الاعمال التجاريه المشروعه
والاختطاف من اجل الحصول على فديه
والادجار بالبشر والمخدرات
تنظيم داعش واخواته كانوا اتخذوا في
السنوات الاخيره من الصحراء الكبرى مقرا
لهم ما يجعل المرحله المقبله منعطفا خطيرا
يخشى يمتد اثارها الى دول المغرب العربي
ودول غرب افريقيا وحتى العالم وفق الامم
المتحده محاسن حضاره العربيه